ich möchte sie heute mitnehmen in die
köpfe in die gedanken und vor allem in
die sorgen der ukrainische
militärführung was die männer dort
beschäftigt womit sie planen müssen und
eben welche sorgen sie haben denn bei
den szenarien den situationen die wir
uns gleich angucken werden da gibt es
immer ein hauptproblem überall wo die
ukrainer sind da sind sie zu wenig
soldaten da haben sie zu wenig
ausrüstung zu wenig panzer am material
um gegen diese russische übermacht
vorzugehen und so muss man eben plan und
so muss man diesen krieg führen ich
möchte dass wir einmal den blick nehmen
von kiew weg und in den osten des landes
schauen denn hier passiert etwas das wir
den ganzen morgen auch schon gehört
haben die russen die dringend nämlich
hier immer weiter vor butt in soldaten
haben hier carson heute erobert das
haben wir gehört eine ganz wichtige
hafenstadt wo man eben auch aus dem vom
wasser aus dann am ende weitere truppen
schicken kann wir sehen dass also hier
unten gebietsgewinne für die russen zu
verbuchen sind von hier immer mehr und
auch hier oben in und um prag if erobern
russische soldaten gebiete und städte
oder zerstören sie einfach in all diesen
gebieten da kämpfen aber nach wie vor
natürlich auch ukrainische soldaten die
ich mal in gelb markiere die erbitterten
widerstand leisten die probieren ihre
heimat ihre familien und ihre kinder zu
verteidigen was nun eine reelle sorge
ist für die ukrainische militärführung
etwas was ich von nato offizieren
erzählt bekommen habe was dort drohen
kann ist wenn dieser vorstoß der russen
weiter geht und womöglich es gelingt von
hier oben aus dem norden von kharkiv in
den süden vorzustoßen und die einheiten
aus dem süden die von hier unten von der
krim kommen wenn die in den norden vor
stoßen dann entsteht hier etwas ein
begriff den wir eigentlich seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg in europa nicht mehr
gehört haben dann würde ich hier ein
kessel entstehen und alle ukrainischen
einheiten die hier noch drin sind die
wären dann umzingelt und umschlossen
werden abgeschlossen von nachschub von
sanität von neuer munition und müssten
sich dann ehrlicherweise ergeben und für
die ukrainische militärführung da kann
eben eine ganz unangenehm frage auf sie
zukommen nämlich an welchem punkt
entscheidet man sich eigentlich hier für
den rückzug aus diesem gebiet um die
soldaten zu schützen um sie ja aus
diesem kessel rechtzeitig raus zu holen
und auf der anderen seite dafür aber den
russen dann natürlich einen riesigen
propaganda erfolg zu geben wenn die
verbuchen könnten hier der gesamte osten
des landes der ist jetzt unter unserer
kontrolle eine ganz schwierige frage die
da auf die generelle hinzu kommt und ich
nehme sie gleich mit in das nächste
dilemma in dem die ukrainischen generäle
stecken denn das hier das ist die
westgrenze der ukraine hier oben kiew
und eben wir richten den blick ganz nach
links auf der karte in den westen hier
da ist die grenze zu polen und dieser
ort hier recht der spielt eine ganz
wichtige rolle denn hier kommt der
nachschub aus dem westen an ich mag ihre
in den einmal diesen ort hier kommen die
flugzeuge an die nachschub bringen nur
flugzeuge der amerikaner hier unten
unser fotograf fotograf wolf luchs der
hat dieses foto machen können am
flughafen ganz besondere situationen und
atmosphäre eine amerikanische galaxien
schwerer schwere transportmaschinen die
da neue waffen entlädt hinten ein
französischer a400m militärtransporter
da kommt also die hilfe an und wird dann
auf
mehr oder weniger geheimen wegen aus
polen in richtung kiew gebracht diese
nachschubroute einmal markiert und
natürlich hier unten drunter dass das
ist auch die fluchtroute in diese
richtung die wir ja schon den ganzen tag
von unseren reportern sehen und passiert
all diese strecke die westfront die
westgrenze die ist bis jetzt mehr oder
weniger ungeschützten klar hier sind
keine russischen soldaten und man
braucht die eigenen truppen gerade an
anderen front verläufen wo eben gekämpft
wird aber was würde passieren wenn es
den russen gelinge hier rein zu kommen
und diese nachschubroute hier zu
unterbrechen einerseits sozusagen zu
verhindern dass menschen weiter fliegen
können und andererseits zu verhindern
dass die wichtigen neuen waffen neuen
soldaten hier hinkommen können ein ganz
großes dilemma und eine schwierige
situation denn nochmal die ukraine
verfügt nicht über unzählige soldaten
die man überall im land verteilen kann
sondern hier eben ein bis jetzt mehr
oder weniger ungeschützter bereich der
aber strategisch ganz ganz wichtig in
den nächsten tagen werden kann ich gehe
wieder rüber und zeigt ihnen die
situation in kiew denn das ist natürlich
die situation die uns am allermeisten
beschäftigt in diesen tagen kiew hier
unten wir wissen die russen die kommen
von nordwesten
und diese attacke aus dem nordwesten
dieser zwischenzeitlich brutal und
erfolgreich aus und ist dann doch ein
stück weit von den ukrainischen truppen
erfolgreich gestoppt oder zumindest
unterbrochen worden ich zeige ihnen
aufnahmen die das belegen und die uns
vor allem zeigen wie das den ukrainern
gelungen ist das hinter mir das war eine
ganz wichtige brücke in einem kleinen
vorort von kiew in ich bin dort machen
die kia war eigentlich ihre
sommerfrische fahren da raus und im
sommer die frische luft die sonne zu
genießen so sieht's da jetzt aus die
brücken sind gesprengt wurden von den
ukrainern selbst um den vormarsch der
russischen panzer auf ihre eigene
hauptstadt eben zu stoppen mit solchen
methoden muss man sich dort mittlerweile
bedienen ich nehme sie weiter mit in
einen anderen vor ort auch hier die
russische armee das video ist etwa zwei
tage alt war dort auf dem vormarsch
dachte man ist auf halben weg nach kiew
und dann ja dann ist das passiert die
bilder die sie wir immer sehen immer
wieder sehen ein russischer konvoi der
hier zum erliegen gekommen ist weil er
eben im gefecht gestoppt wurde und es
hier kein weiteres vordringen für die
russin gab ich will ihnen zeigen was die
russische armee danach gemacht hat in
diesem ort sie hat man kann das glaube
ich so sagen
vergeltungsschläge verübt das hier das
ist eine straßenszene hier noch gut zu
sehen dass eben die ukrainische fahne
weht und jetzt richten sie gleich einmal
ihren blick hierhin hier fährt ein
russischer panzer auf und achten sie
darauf wenn man vielleicht das bild ins
vollbild leicht nehmen was dieser
russische panzer macht und wohin er
schießen wird die rakete des panzers die
schlägt nämlich nur wenige meter unter
dem mann der das video hier macht ein
ich zeige ihnen die situation nochmal
urbanes gelände statt
links und rechts leben menschen und der
panzer der nimmt dann das wohnhaus ins
visier und feuer total rein
großes glück für den kameramann dass er
diese situation offenbar überlebt hat
und dann wenige tage später das video
ist dann von gestern wie sieht's heute
in diesem ort aus dort wo die ukraine so
erbittert widerstand geleistet haben ich
zeige ihnen von diesem ort so ist
nämlich nicht mehr viel möglich viel
übrig borodjanka heißt der und schauen
sie das hat die russische artillerie mit
diesem ort gemacht hier sehen wir es
noch ein spielplatz ist hier auch
getroffen worden der eben ja auch am
ende ins visier der russischen raketen
gekommen ist die dort wohnblöcke
vernichtet haben wohnungen vernichtet
haben und einfach alles zerstört haben
was sich ihnen in den weg gestellt hat
wir hatten also fest die russische armee
die probiert weiter eben den kessel und
kiew zu schließen vom westen vom
nordwesten da wird aber erbitterter
widerstand geleistet diese offensive die
scheint zumindest in teilen naja
vielleicht gebremst zu sein und auf der
anderen seite hören wir aber auch immer
mehr dass sich nun von osten der ring um
kiew weiter schließen könnte dass in
diesen minuten die situation auf die
eben die ukrainische militärführung
genau gucken muss